aquí estamos a menos de 10 kilómetros de
uno de los principales frentes de la
región de doñesque el frente más cercano
está en dirección en este momento se
están produciendo fuertes combates en el
otro lado
la artillería ucraniana esta
bombardeando a sus oponentes rusos esta
posición
no queremos sentarnos en los puestos de
control queremos luchar en primera línea
el comandante puede llamarte por la
noche y decirte que los rusos están
planeando un ataque con tanques ordena
hasta tu Batallón que defienda su
sección en el frente y tus soldados
lucharán contra los tanques no es una
broma es un enfrentamiento fuerte
los combates no son solo para los
voluntarios ucranianos este soldado es
un ciudadano ruso No dudó ni un segundo
antes de tomar las armas para luchar
contra los soldados de su propio país
hoy solo tiene una cosa en mente
lucha contra los que no tienen honor
tanto si son de tu propia familia como
si no no importa Rusia es el mal a
escala mundial si hay un conflicto en
cualquier lugar encontrarán la mano el
Krilin
estoy 99 100% seguro de eso
otros aprovechan su experiencia en la
vida civil para usarla por la causa Este
es el caso de chatarra
cuando trabajaban las minas había
explosiones y un tipo murió a dos metros
de mí así que estoy tranquilo Cuando veo
la muerte no puedo decir que en ningún
momento Tuve miedo
Bueno
más después de que los separatistas
tomaron el control de partes de donetsky
en 2014 ahora ha vuelto a su región más
decidido que nunca
a pesar de sus diferentes orígenes estos
voluntarios de la defensa del territorio
están unidos por una causa común
defender a Su patria con todas sus
fuerzas y por todos los medios solo
estar en su tercer mes de combate pero
su falta de experiencia probablemente
pueda compensarse en parte con las armas
más potentes que están llegando aquí y
que empiezan a marcar la diferencia en
muchos frentes